hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over my favorite way
to attack
the ponziani opening and that is with
the ponziani counter gambit ponziano
starts out with e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 and then white
plays
c3 preparing to push forward and control
the center
of the board and many players as black
don't understand exactly how to
defend correctly and they play too
passively and then they just get
overwhelmed because white's able to push
forward here with d4
really control the center of the board
and then white black has a very cramped
position
but the counter game it says if you want
to try to attack the center of the board
we're gonna attack just as much as you
are and so it plays the move
f5 now black's going to give up this
pawn and material
in exchange for a very strong attack in
the center of the board now some gambits
are very different
some you give up material and you never
really expect to get that back but you
expect to have a very very
strong attack against your opponent in
this gambit you're
eventually going to be able to get that
material back
so just keep that in mind as you are
playing this
but you do need to understand
conceptually what we're trying to do
in this counter gambit now there are
lots of lines that white can take
in this video today we are going to be
going over the accepted line which is
the pond takes here on f5
they could decline that they could just
push forward here
with uh d4 uh they could get their
bishop involved into the game so they
have
other options if you guys want to see
the decline lines
uh not taking here on f5 feel free to
let me know
in the comments below and i'll
definitely
make videos on what you want to see so
definitely open to making a video on the
decline lines but in this video we're
going to be going
over the accepted lines which is the
pawn takes here on
f5
now from here black is going to respond
with queen
to f6 anytime you give up material
especially in a gambit
you usually want to have a very strong
attack and getting the queen involved in
this opening
is a key component to that and the queen
supporting this pawn
as well as attacking this pawn here on
f5 are going to be very very
important if you try just immediately to
push forward with
d5 then it gets troublesome with bishop
to b5 because
really the threat that they have here is
the knight takes here on
e5 double attacking this night the
knights being
pinned so it gets pretty tricky for
black you know they could play
a bishop to d6 defending this pawn right
here
maybe d4 and then they push forward
recognize that not all these moves are
are forced
but it's difficult to find better
options for both sides so maybe knight
to
e5 they take right here
take our knight here on c6 check after
we take with our pawn
queen down here to h5 check there's no
way to
stop the check i don't want to just play
g6 because then they could just take
with the pawn right here so instead
going to move the king here
on f8 and then after the pawn takes here
queen two e8 we could see an exchange
castle on the king side
uh so both sides are equal in material
here
but you can see that white has a very
very
strong pawn structure compared to black
it's tough to see how black's actually
going to have
a productive game it's really just going
to be trying to get a drawl
out of this so that's not necessarily
what we're looking for so
after the pawn takes not looking to push
forward with a d5 quite yet instead
going to be looking to play queen
to f6
and there's a few options that you'll
see from white here they could just push
forward with d4 that's the main reason
that they were playing c3
is to attack the center of the board
with protection from the pawn
they could also play bishop to b5
preparing to castle on the king side
this also attacks the knight which is
controlling the center of the board
they also could play some really weird
stuff so we'll go over if they just
played you know d3
uh which maybe they decide hey we're
going to be pushing forward with e4
and so that stops the threat of coming
here to e4 so we'll look at the first
one and that is with
d4 now we're just gonna push forward we
are attacking
the knight right here and so they have a
few options as far as how they can
respond now
if they play queen to e2 because many
times if they're
you push forward with your pawn
attacking the knights they'll usually
play queen to e2 at some point
in chess this is not just this opening
but they usually play queen to e2 but
now black has pawn to d5 and you can see
because we'll look at other variations
and how it's going to be different is
this bishop here on f1 is
blocked by the queen so it's not as good
to bring the queen to e2 if it's
blocking the bishop because
white doesn't really want to castle on
the queen side
because the pawn structure is not really
built for king safety and it also is
going to take a few moves
for white to actually get to a position
where it can cast on the queen side
it's going to be very difficult now to
castle on the king side because the
light squared bishop
is blocked in and so this is not really
the best option for white to bring the
queen here to e2 so it really comes down
to where
is the knight going to move okay well
you have knight to e5
it may look like it's an outpost because
the pawn is protecting it but it's just
not going to work out well the knight
takes
pawn takes here uh queen uh
takes here on e5 next move you could
have the pawn push forward here to d5
you could have the queen take here on f5
and you can see that white doesn't have
any of their pieces developed
black has the only central pawn on the
board
this is going to be completely fine for
black so definitely not
the best option for white could also
play knight to
d2 in this case i would go ahead and
take with the queen here
on f5 i think it gets a little bit
dangerous if you don't because this
square here on
h5 is actually a real threat that white
has so if you play
uh pawn to d5 just saying the i'll
we'll go and open this up i can take
this pawn here with my bishop on f5
then they can play queen down here to h5
and then you're really going to be
playing queen comes back here to
f7 and then the queen takes the king
recaptures it's just not
as good of an opening as you would like
so
instead you really want to be taking
this pawn here to stop
this queen 2 h5 so instead of
d5 we're going to just be playing queen
takes here
on f5 now it is somewhat odd also for
them to bring their knight back here to
d2 just want to make sure that you are
prepared if
they do that because this is blocking
off both the knight coming here to d2
which it's already blocked off on c3
it's also blocking off the dark square
bishop here so
the other option that you could see is
knight to
g5 this is protected by the bishop
here on c1 and it also attacks this pawn
here on
e4
and this is the best option for white
and so black's going to play
d5 this supports the pawn here on e4
black has both central pawns also opens
up for the light square
bishop to attack this pawn here on f5
and white has a few options from here
the best lines would be either to get
their queen here to h5 which then we can
just block with
g6 and even if they take we can
recapture with our pawn you usually
don't want to do this because your rook
is hanging
but our queen is actually protecting the
h8 square so they can't take that
they're going to be forced to move their
queen back
and then we just play bishop to f5
getting ready to castle on
the queen side get our rook activated we
have
all of our pieces opened up here so this
is definitely one option
if you see the queen come involved into
the game to h5
they could also just play uh g4
trying to add another defender on this
f5 square but you can also see this
weakens the king side for
castling for white either way
black's going to be able to castle to
the queen side and put a lot of pressure
on
white's king because where does white
really castle from here so their king's
usually going to be in the center of the
board
for a while but now we can just push
forward with h5 and if they take here
that's fine
because that was the defender on this f5
square we can take with our bishop here
maybe bishop comes down to b5
just trying to activate we could play
knight to e7 if we want to but
we can look to castle on the queen side
they may not even get their bishop
involved into the game
just showing you a few options of what
you could see
now after the move queen to f6 from the
beginning they may not push forward with
d4 because they see our pawn right here
and they may not just want to worry
about the pawn pushing forward to e4
so they may play bishop to b5
get the bishop outside so that the queen
at some point can come to e2 which makes
a lot of sense also preparing to castle
on the king side
many players if they face a gambit or a
counter gambit
they usually like to have king safety
and so bishop to b5
allows for that now there's a few
options of what you could see
from here but first we're going to start
with
e4 and this puts pressure on
the knight now they could play queen to
e2 and you can see how different this is
than when the bishop was here on f1
because now we can't take with our pawn
it's pinned down by the queen to the
king here
but it's not necessarily as bad for
whites because they can still castle on
the king's hat but they may not play the
queen to e2 quite yet we'll look at that
option as well
but they could just play knight to d4
this is an outpost it's defended by the
pawn here on
c3 if that's the case though we're just
going to take with our knight if they
take with their pawn
we push forward with c6 almost the
ponziani on our own
with c6 and then pushing forward at d5
at some point
so maybe bishop e2 and then pawn to
d5 opening up four lights or bishop to
take here on f5
capture or castle on the queen side so
that's going to be pretty good for
us now if they don't play the knights
maybe they just say
we'll just take with our bishop then we
can recapture with our pawn and maybe
now they play queen
to e2 and we can block the pin
with bishop to e7
this is a common line that you may see
and you can
start to see the power of the counter
gambit as you get all of your pieces
involved into the game
but now they may decide okay we'll go
ahead and take that pawn here on
e4 but now we can play bishop takes on
f5 attacking the queen the queen comes
back to
e3 now we castle on the queen side it's
all about getting all your material
involved into the action so they may
castle on
the king side and then we play rook to
d3 and the reason i like this because
you have a couple options you could play
bishop to d3
this bishop's protected by the rook here
this is attacking the rook
the reason i like rook to d3 is because
if they look at this and say well shoot
my queen is under attack here i need to
move my queen where can i go can i
gobble up material
i'll just go ahead and gobble up
material here on a7 that's a pretty
easy play for them to make but that's
going to be a huge mistake where
if you just play your bishop here to d3
they can just play
rook 2 e1 and then you're not really
threatening the queen right here and so
it's more difficult i think for them to
make a huge mistake but
it's pretty logical to play rook to d3
and then queen to a7 and not recognize
the massive threat that you have but the
threat
is the rook takes here on f3
if they take the rook on f3 it's game
over it's a forced mate they can't stop
it because you have
bishop two h3 and then we're going to be
threatening queen
to f3 and then queen to
g2 and there's no way to stop it we
really just baited them to bring their
queen here to a7
the queen is never able to get back and
stop
what black is trying to do here
you can see that the pawn here on c6 is
keeping it so that the
queen here is never able to attack
or defend this square here on f3 and
they can make an attempt maybe queen to
aaa
check and then king d7 and then queen up
here to a4
but after queen takes on f3
there's no way to stop the mate so if we
come back
we can see that the pawn can't take the
rook here
so how do they really respond okay well
they could play
g3 but then
we could play bishop two h3
and maybe rook two e1 but then black has
an even better move and that is the rook
takes on
c3 and they still can't take it let's
say
knight takes on c3 well now we have
queen to
f3 preparing to mate here on g2 and they
still have all the ways that they can
try to prolong this game that's fine but
at the end of the day it's going to be
checkmate so they can't stop that as
well so this rook here
on d3 that's why early on i say go ahead
and play that rook to
d3 it's so dangerous because it gives it
an opportunity to make a mistake and
that's what i'm always trying to do put
my
opponent in a position where they can
make a mistake i don't want them to
look at this and say okay why i don't i
haven't been in this position before but
if
they're attacking my rook i'll move my
rook and i'm going to move it to e1 that
makes a lot of sense but
if you play this if they know they have
to move their queen it makes a lot of
sense to play queen
to a7 so that's um some different ways
that you could
uh play early on if they take with their
bishop here
on uh c6 now they may not
instead of taking with the bishop here
on
c6 they could also just play queen to e2
now in this case i recommend playing
queen to e7 to block this
off not playing the bishop to e7
now because the pawns no longer pinned
we can take their knight so they
probably need to move
their knights and so if they play knight
to
d4 we could just take with our knights
if they take we can still play the same
thing
c6 now they have a couple options they
don't have to just move their bishop
right away they could play the queen to
a5 check now we're just going to bring
our queen over here if they take that's
fine now they move their bishop back we
play pawn
to d5 opening up for our bishop
to get involved into the action our
king's not as bad here on f7
because the queens are off the board
here and even if they come to maybe g4
they take here we take with their bishop
but it's gonna be difficult for them to
hold on to this pawn the rest of the
game double pawns on the
the outside the h or the a file are the
hardest to hold on to
um and so eventually black's going to be
able to get that material back
if they don't play the queen to h5
because
it does look like an odd move sometimes
they could just bring their bishop back
so
they could play you know bishop to a4
if they they wanted to and then you
could just play d5
preparing for bishop takes here on f5
those definitely are the main things
that you'll see you also could see some
some weird stuff if you play queen to f6
they could play
a d3 just go ahead and take the material
here
on f5 don't try to get cute with
anything else
it's tough to even figure out how
they're going to continue here maybe
bishop to e2 getting ready to castle on
the king side the bishop can't go
anywhere else and they may be confused
and trying to
play somewhat passive so this could make
some sense but just
start to take over play d5 you already
got your material back now you can
control the center of the board
maybe castle on the king side you play
knight to f6 here that seems fine uh
maybe they recognize their mistake and
now play d4
but now you could play e4 and it's it's
even better before because now if they
play bishop to e2
you can play bishop to e7 you've already
taken that pawn back so
this is going to be very fine it's
difficult to see how they're really
going to
continue here if they play knight to
g5 we play knight to f6 here
then we can start to push forward with
h6
very difficult to see how white comes
out of this you can see they
can't play their light square bishop
it's blocked off black and castle on the
king
side can also at some point play d5
light square bishop involved castle on
the queen side so i feel like black has
a lot more options
uh than white if they don't play queen
to e2
they could also try knight to h4
but then we just bring our queen back
here to f7 this is a fine square for the
the queen to be at
um you could still play bishop to e7
after this
and this is that's a real threat i mean
bishop to e7 where does
the white knight go to it doesn't have
any good squares
and so this is you know pretty good
square for the bishop so that's going to
be the next move that i would play
for black so that is the ponziani
counter game bit my favorite way to
attack
if your opponent ever tries that sneaky
c3
where they think i'm going to catch my
opponent off guard they're not going to
know what to do because i'm going to
control the center of the board
you can just strike back with the third
move of
f5 so thank you guys so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video if you
wouldn't mind hitting
that like button also if you want to see
the decline lines because they don't
have to take here
uh there i will make another video on
the decline lines there's about two or
three lines that i think would be
beneficial to know
so if you want to see that feel free to
let me know but thank you guys so much
for watching and i'll see you
in the next video